S
US AWAY FROM A DRONE OR MISSILE
THAT WOULDN'T HAVE A WAR HEAD
THAT SIZE.
>>> A SENIOR NATO OFFICIAL IS
WARNING THAT A POTENTIAL RUSSIAN
NUCLEAR STRIKE WOULD ALMOST
CERTAINLY TRIGGER A PHYSICAL
RESPONSE FROM MANY ALLIES,
POTENTIALLY FROM NATO ITSELF.
THE COMMENTS CAME AS DEFENSE
MINISTERS DISCUSSED HOW TO BEST
HELP UKRAINE.
AS RUSSIA CONTINUES THE AERIAL
BOMBARDMENT OF UKRAINE, PUTIN
HAS BEEN MAKING VEILED THREATS
OF A NUCLEAR ATTACK.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT ABOUT
THESE NUCLEAR THREATS.
TO BE CLEAR, U.S. OFFICIALS THEY
SAY THEY DON'T THINK THAT RUSSIA
IS ABOUT TO USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS
BUT WHAT THEY SAY IS THEY ARE
LISTENING TO THE THREATS AND
TAKING THEM SERIOUSLY.
YOU WORKED IN THIS FIELD.
TALK TO US ABOUT, IN THEORY, HOW
RUSSIA MIGHT USE TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> A TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPON IS
REALLY A BORDER WEAPON IT HAS
RANGE OF 15 TO 20 MILES.
BUT TREMENDOUS DESTRUCTION
CAPABILITY.
LOOK AT A SITUATION WHERE RUSSIA
HAS A DOCTRINE THAT SAYS WE
ESCALATE WITH NUCLEAR WEAPONS TO
DE-ESCALATE SHOULD WE BE
ATTACKED CONVENTIONALLY.
YOU SEE RUSSIAN TROOPS ON THIS
SIDE OF THE RIVER.
AS THEY GET PUSHED ACROSS HERE,
THAT RIVER BECOMES THE NATURAL
BOUNDARY THAT RUSSIA WILL CLAIM
THEY CAN FIRE NUCLEAR WEAPONS
INTO THIS AREA THAT WOULD RENDER
THAT AREA USELESS, YOU WON'T
HAVE ANY OFFENSIVE OPERATIONS
THERE AND KEEP UKRAINE TROOPS
OUT OF IT.
I THINK THE TARGET WILL BE
UKRAINE MILITARY.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO, IT FORCES
THEM INTO PLAY, IT DOESN'T ALLOW
THEM TO MOVE.
>> NO ONE IS SAYING THAT THIS
WILL HAPPEN.
THIS IS A SUGGESTION OF HOW
RUSSIA COULD USE THESE WEAPONS.
AND IT WOULD BE TO TAKE THIS
ENTIRE AREA OFF THE BATTLEFIELD,
SOME WAYS TAKING IT OFF THE
EARTH TALKING ABOUT TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
YOU WERE IN THIS FIELD IN THE
'80s, WHAT DID THE U.S. LEARN OR
THINK ABOUT WHETHER NUCLEAR
WEAPONS COULD BE USED IN A
LIMITED WAY?
>> WE REALIZED IT WASN'T THE
DETERRENT WE THOUGHT IT WAS
GOING TO BE.
WE HAD TACTICAL TROOPS WELL
POSITIONED IN GERMANY IN THE
TIME AND USE THEM AS A RETREAT
AND WITHDRAW AS RUSSIAN TROOPS
WERE COMING, WE WERE OUTNUMBERED
6 TO 1 AT THE TIME, WE HAD NO
EXPECTATIONS WE NEEDED THE
WEAPONS TO KEEP THE RUSSIAN
TROOPS FROM COMING TOWARDS US,
IT RENDERS THE LAND WORTHLESS AS
THEY COME THROUGH THE NUCLEAR
WASTE LAND THEY'RE EXPOSED TO
RADIO ACTIVE AND INCREASES THE
CASUALTIES.
>> THE IDEA OF A LIMITED NUCLEAR
USE, THERE WAS NO WAY TO LIMIT
IT.
ONCE YOU START IT ROLLS OUT OF
CONTROL.
>> YES.
ESCALATING.
AND WE GO FROM TACTUAL TO
STRATEGIC NUKES SO HOW ARE THEY
DELIVERED?
ARTILLERY TUBES THAT'S ONE
THING.
BUT SUBMARINES OR COMING FROM
THE AIR, THAT CHANGES THEM.
THEY'RE NOW STRATEGIC NUKES AND
THOSE CAN GO DEEPER IN UKRAINE.
>> LET'S GO BACK TO WHAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
WE'VE SEEN THE RUSSIANS HITTING
UKRAINE ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
FROM THE AIR.
THE UKRAINIANS CLAIM THEY'RE
SHOOTING DOWN ABOUT HALF OF THE
RUSSIAN MISSILES COMING IN.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S AN
ACCURATE NUMBER OR NOT.
BUT WHAT WOULD THE UKRAINIANS
NEED IN ORDER TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES?
>> THEY NEED MORE ADVANCED AIR
DEFENSE PLATFORMS.
THEY WON'T GET THEM IN TIME.
WE'RE CLAIMING WE'RE GOING TO
SEND THEM BETTER SYSTEMS, BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS RUSSIA IS
USING THE SUPERSONIC AND
HYPERSONIC MISSILES.
THERE'S NO CAPABILITY TO SHOOT
THEM DOWN.
I THINK THE NUMBERS ARE HIGHLY
EXAGGERATED.
IT DOESN'T APPEAR THER